our 8 news now investigators are looking  into what led up to the murder of review  journal investigative reporter Jeff  gearman Clark County public  administrator Robert Tellis is accused  of killing him and he remains in jail  this afternoon Telus was denied bail  during a court appearance yesterday the  judge cited DNA evidence in her decision  eight news now investigator Vanessa  Murphy asked Clark County district  attorney Steve Wolfson about the events  that happened Wednesday when Telus was  released by police hours before he was  officially arrested  the family of Jeff gearman has set up a  donation page to honor him with a local  charity there they chose three Square  which helps people dealing with food  insecurity family says they want to  thank everyone in the community for the  outpouring of love and support and  recognition for Jeff and his life's work